Speaker 1: So I've talked before about
the problem of chiropractors, and
now we are actually seeing chiropractors who many
of whom are are anti-vaccine. And I'll talk about
what I mean when I say many chiropractors
are increasingly a force of misinformation,
as reported by The Associated Press. Oh, let's
read a little bit of this article, and then I'm
going to give you some of my thoughts. This
is an article from Providence, Rhode Island,
about a event called Vax Con 21, promoted
as teaching people the uncensored truth
about COVID vaccines and people went. Participants
traveled from around the country to a Wisconsin
Dells resort for a sold out convention that was
a sea of misinformation and conspiracy theories.
The featured speaker was the anti-vax
activist from the 2020 movie Plandemic.
The convention was organized by members of a
profession that has become a major purveyor
of vaccine misinformation during the pandemic.
Chiropractors at a time when the surgeon general
says misinformation has become an urgent threat
to public health. An investigation by the AP
found a vocal and influential group of
chiropractors capitalizing on the pandemic
by sowing fear and mistrust of vaccines. They've
touted supplements as alternatives to vaccines.
Written doctor's notes to allow patients to
get out of mask and immunization mandates
donated large sums of money to anti-vaccine
organizations and sold anti-vaccine ads
on Facebook and Instagram, the AP discovered. One
chiropractor gave thousands to a superPAC hosting
anti-vaccine pro-Trump rally on January 6th.
They have also been the leading force behind
anti-vax events like the one in Wisconsin, where
hundreds of chiropractors from around the country
shelled out $299 to attend. The AP found
chiropractors were allowed to earn continuing
ad credits to maintain their licenses in at least
10 states. Going on to say public health advocates
are alarmed by the number of chiropractors
hitching themselves to the anti-vaccine movement,
using their public prominence and sheen of
medical expertize to undermine the nation's
response to a pandemic that has killed 700000.
So let's talk about chiropractors, OK? I'm not
100 percent against chiropractors. I'm about 85
percent against them. And here's what what I'll
tell you by that. When you in some places, people
go to a chiropractor almost like a primary care
doctor. In fact, in California, chiropractors can
be peacekeepers, and they are often anti-vaccine,
and they often promote a ton of different
Wu. So the stuff from chiropractors that's
a disaster includes things like the anti-vaccine
stuff, as well as chiropractic adjustments,
as treatments for systemic conditions
of different kinds, infections,
etc. neck adjustments, back adjustments,
etc. just simply no evidence that they treat
infections and other systemic conditions. OK.
Number two, a lot of chiropractors are in the Wu
stuff like and you can see some of these
on YouTube. I mean, there's people that go
to chiropractors on YouTube, they film it and you
hear stuff like make sure to drink a lot of extra
water after the adjust adjustment to flush out the
toxins released by the back cracking and the neck
stuff that I did, that's total nonsense. I mean,
just when you think about how the body works,
drink water to flush through the kidneys for
an adjustment, it just doesn't make sense. OK,
so that you've got to be very, very careful with
next stuff. Check out on YouTube and articles
from spine surgeons and back surgeons about the
risk of neck adjustments and what can happen from
neck manipulations done by chiropractors. So
all of this stuff is horrible. Huge. You know,
at at best, you're spending money on something
that will do nothing, and at worst you can end
up really hurt. Now what's the part that maybe
is OK? There are some things chiropractors do
that are also done by physical therapists
and are more within the realm of reality
as long as you understand their goal.
So like, for example, I once went to
a physical therapist when I was having some
back pain and they do some very specific
back cracking things, not where you put a strap
under your neck and pull to extent. No, but just
some specific back things, which they say this
is not really treatment. But while we're building
a routine for you to strengthen muscles and maybe
deal with a spasm or whatever, some of these
specific backtracking can provide some short term
relief. OK. Beyond that, we've got to be really
careful with chiropractors. So it's not a surprise
that this is a group that is doing things that are
horrible, including as we covered in Florida
saying, just come on down and I'll sign off on
a mask or vac vaccine exemption for you. And that
is extraordinarily concerning, and I'm really glad
that the AP is writing about this. It says the
purveyors of vaccine misinformation represent
a small but vocal minority of the nation's
70000 chiropractors, many of whom advocate
for vaccines. So I think that that's important
and what I've said to people when they say so
should no one go to a chiropractor, I this is not
my idea. You can find this information online.
What should be done if you're considering going
to a chiropractor is you call up and you actually
ask their view on chiropractic adjustments and
you say, Do you believe chiropractic adjustments
can be used to, for example, treat things like
sinus infections or, you know, cancer? Imagine.
What's your view on vaccination, et cetera?
You can usually pretty quickly, if you ask
there's like five or six questions you can find
online to ask a possible chiropractor. You can
pretty quickly suss out like which which side of
things they're on. You can also more than likely
get what you need from a physical therapist. And
there you're talking about a different, different
type of setting, and that may be something to
consider as well, but chiropractors increasingly
a source of anti-vaccine disinformation. Nation.
Let's move on to another source of disinformation.